le world food day s'invita voisins le
bretonneux cette opération citoyenne a
réuni 70 habitants mégots canettes
bouteilles paquets de cigarettes ou
encore papier tout a été ramassé et jeté
à la poubelle
je pense que garder la ville propre
c'est quelque chose qui doit être qui
doit rentrer dans l'adn de chaque vie si
noah et s'il faut passer par des
opérations coup de poing comme comme
celle ci est bien nous allons le faire
mais l'objectif est que vraiment tout le
monde se
se prennent en main et nettoie au jour
le jour les participants petits et
grands ont pris la mesure des déchets
dans leur ville grâce à cet événement
j'ai ramassé les déchets de mon quartier
comme ça c'est la ville elle est propre
et ça me fait plaisir surtout on a été
étonné à la fois deux du nombre de
mégots qui traînaient partout ça c'était
vraiment le cas limités à la fin du
ramassage près de 250 kg de déchets ont
été récoltés ces opérations étaient
organisés également à montigny le
bretonneux maurepas villepreux ou encore
plaisir